[Music]
it's time for roses and rosette oh I got
a little tangled up it's been a while
everybody last week on episode whine of
Nick vile season of The Bachelor I was
on meds on antibiotics couldn't be
drinking and appears
I forgot how but I'm sure I'll remember
very quickly here we go episode 2 of
Nick vile season and these ladies came
to play things started off like a comic
book with a slap a bang Jimmy that you
guys cooked up and had sex the ladies
start off with an interesting group date
they're all tasked to take wedding
photos with Nick and this photographer
aka Robin Williams from The Birdcage
fussy fussy fussy you do Martha Graham
Martha Graham Martha Graham is gonna
help him do it so each of the ladies
gets a type of photo to be and Corinne
is upset because this girl whose name I
forget gets to be the topless one an
extra small bikini bottom
Corina wants to make it known that being
topless guys that sort of thing
I did just go into this photo shop with
no clothes I actually was daring enough
to have clothes and take them off
Wow
very cute so Corrine wins the challenge
because in the beginning The Bachelor
can't tell who the villain is so the
villain always wins the challenges and
then later that night karena interrupts
everybody like over and over again she's
interrupting everybody 72 interruptions
and guess what she gets a rose because
in the beginning the villains win the
challenges then someone interrupts
Corinne keep ringing interrupting me
which I carry I interrupted Taylor and
then she came and Marie interrupted me
there's a way to go about things so I
didn't go foul things is very classy but
don't worry because Corinne is proud of
everything she's done tonight
all her toplessness included and she
knows her dad would be too hey stepped
on my comfort zone many different times
and angles dad would be proud even
though I was naked he would be proud
cheers to Corinne and her dad he's out
there probably doing what I'm doing then
back to Liz in Episode one we learned
that Liz and Nick hooked up at Jaden
Tanner's wedding before and it was ever
the bachelor and Liz just can't keep the
secret in anymore she feels like Nick's
ignoring her so she tells Kristen and
Kristen promises she is not gonna tell
anybody I would never say a word about
it and they wouldn't even know that I
knew but drink if you think Kristen's
gonna tell somebody Kristen told
somebody so they go on a group date to
the Museum of broken relationships where
they all have to break up with Nick I'm
not really sure what the lesson or
takeaway was here and then Liz broke up
with Nick in this real weird way I've
been hurt and I wasn't ready to let you
pull in
many guys have been on the opposite side
of that situation before but listen to
the way he says okay okay have you ever
heard so much animosity in the way
someone said okay okay cut to later and
guess what Kristen tells Nick what she
knows to Jew me that you guys hooked up
and had sex
I was surprised by this Nick since Liz
home
I just don't know we have tissue
this thing is best for both of us um if
I say goodbye tonight drink of you were
surprised Wow one of my eyelashes just
fell out
well no none of them are real so that's
the end of it nixon's was home and we
cut the dramatic to be continued we know
it's gonna be continued it's on every
week I know and why did they bother with
that so far guys loving this season I
mean you don't know what Nick vials
gonna do let me know what you thought of
this episode over on Twitter and make
sure to subscribe to et on YouTube
because we are gonna be here talking
about The Bachelor and drink into it
every week I'm still recovering from my
illness but you know this will probably
just clean out my insides have a great
[Music]
you